[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions this is the Ramsey Show it's
where we help you win in your life
specifically with your money your
relationships and in your work
8825 5225 is the phone number that's
8825 5225 I'm Ken Coleman joined by John
delone and we are here for you this hour
the good doctor is in the sign is
hanging on the door so that means
relationship the mental health questions
related to money are just in that
category and uh we have a lot of fun
together and we'll talk about your work
as well if you feel like I need a bigger
shovel I need more money to get through
those baby steps I feel like I'm
overlooked I don't know what I want to
do whatever so we're taking all those
questions your your money your
relationships your work
8825 5225 question for you before we
take a quick call when you check in at a
hotel do you drop the doctor on them no
you've earned it no I don't I appreciate
that I don't because we have a mutual
friend Dr Les parrot and I'm outing him
he watches the show so this is for him
he watches on TBN when he checks in he
goes Dr Les no he doesn't I promise you
oh no and it irritates me yeah and so
this is my right mom and my my wife were
Dr deloney long before I was right and
so I've got so you didn't feel like well
by the time I I got around to it they're
like oh that's cute and they patted me
on the head and we'd already done the
celebrating so so there you go sorry Les
we love you my mom named me John there
it is I love it all right let's get to
Ryan who's joining us now in Orlando
Florida Ryan how can we help yeah good
afternoon guys and thanks for taking the
time to talk to me today sure what's
going on um well I would like to know my
question outright is should I hire a CPA
to help get my wife on board with
budgeting and so here had said I know
avoidance cannot be a strategy and I
think that's why I'm reaching out is
because we are avoiding
we we we don't fight about money because
we the conversation never gets started
and we've been married 11 years okay
usually I seek out a professional when
me trying to do it will a I can't do the
task whether
it's you know um changing the shocks on
my car or re-roofing my house or you
know trimming trees I don't know how to
do it or me trying to do it is going to
make it really bad so have you tried to
talk budgeting with your wife I I have
and I would tell you that um in the past
you know she has shut down um she's had
panic attacks I usually get an I can't
today or will defer to I trust you babe
and and you know I take it as a
compliment but it leavs me nowhere and
do do you come at her with
spreadsheets uh I have provided one I've
never put it in her face but I said when
you're ready to talk about it I have one
made and I've had one made for 11 years
let me ask a question here so when she
defa you said she gave you two answers
not today or I trust you babe so when
she says I trust you
babe do you actually then create the
budget and execute on it or absolutely
did she does she fight against it nope
so why do you need to hire a CPA when
she's essentially following the budget
she just doesn't want to do it here's
the doozy uh we keep separate accounts
because she is paranoid of having um any
financial responsibility all of the cars
the house everything's in my name
because she chooses to not have her name
on it do you budget does not want that I
get it uh do you budget money for her or
is it her income goes in her account and
so this budget we've been talking about
is just your income in your account
explain that to us correct but but I do
track and I know what her cyclical are I
just don't influence them in any way oh
man the onion is there's the onion is
unpeeling for us here um so I'm here's
the best way I can say this this is just
me as a guy who grew up living in
Texas I walk to you and I can say hey my
name is John what's your name
or I could walk up to you where you're
where you're in Orlando say
h you too when you come at your wife
with a spreadsheet and say hey I would
like to talk budgets with
you she knows a she can't compete with
you B somewhere along the line in her
world the fear of being left underneath
the weight of a bunch of expenditures
has set her body on in in to figh ORF
flight and solving that with instad data
is almost never the right way to
approach
it if you were to approach her with hey
honey I'm scared to death to do this by
myself or I'm so
lonely would you please talk to me about
this because I feel like I'm on an
island now you're talking a different
language you're talking a language of
somebody who's who whose emotions feel
like they're on fire whose feelings feel
hot now I can understand that language I
understand what you're trying to say to
me the spreadsheet we get to after we
get through all of the layers yeah but
John I got to jump in I think that's
great advice but the first issue is they
have separate accounts and you you're
nailing the trauma issue but she can't
for some reason she doesn't trust this
guy that's what I'm getting at yeah
that's the bigger issue it's not the
that's where I think he has to come in
and say hey I'm not I haven't proven
myself trustworthy to you yet for any
number of reasons and it might not be
you
but laying it out that way and saying I
need an I'm I'm giving you an invitation
here right hiring a CPA is just hiring a
bigger spreadsheet and calculator by the
way the CPA is going to hate you yeah
because once he realizes what you've
hired him for he's be like I'm out yeah
you need a marriage counselor before you
need a CPA brother yeah because the the
roots of this thing Ken's right the
roots of this thing are deeper than
budgets do you know Ryan specifically
what John what the roots are here that
she's what's going on to where she is
this way and doesn't want to have a
joint account she had a financially
controlling stepfather that kept them on
the wrong side of uh they were withheld
from everything growing up Tada ding
ding ding and here's the thing um she
had a a tough um a tough childhood and
it sucks and the the pain there is real
the trauma There's real the nervous
system wearing's
real and then she looked at you and said
I do mhm and so now she has a a choice
am I going to bury this
marriage in in Memorial to the trauma I
had I'm going to recreate it here or I'm
going to do the terrifying scary thing
and I am going to seek
healing that's a choice she has to make
but that's not you don't start it with
that choice with a with a with a 10 key
with a
calculator okay you start that choice
with I want to build a United marriage
because my I promise you that's not the
only thing yall are separate on
Fair I don't no this is the we we get
along great we have regular talks I feel
like this is the only thing I would love
to talk to her I guarantee you how long
you guys been married uh 11 years 11 and
a half years yeah John I I'm interested
to see what you think of this I I want
to recommend to Ryan that he pay for
counseling sessions yeah absolutely HIM
lead here nice dinners or whatever
beforehand like to where she feels super
safe and supported not like hey I'm
taking you here to get this fixed but I
do agree with you this is a therapy is
this is a bigger issue my promise if you
have everything in your life is on on
point it's all together you're connected
and it's just this weird thing over here
that that happens so so rarely there's
something in her world that says she's
not safe I think that's where we start
what do you think about a free copy for
his wife own your past absolutely own
your past and building an un anxious
life that can give you a road map to
creating something new in your house so
you can talk about money Ryan hang on
the line Austin will get you both books
that's a gift but don't force them on
her just bless her with this is the
rangy
[Music]
[Applause]
show
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman Dr John deloney joins me in
studio here this hour
8825 5225 8825 5225 hey uh if you've
been listening to the show or watching
the show for a while and you've got a
question but you're nervous can I just
tell you we're going to make you feel
really comfortable at least try and
we're not against you we're for you and
we're not here to shame you we're here
to support you so um give us a call
88255 225 money question relationship
question mental health question work
related questions we're here for you
Logan is up in Helena Montana Logan how
can we
help hi guys uh just want to say thank
you first off for taking the time to
answer this question so I purchased a
vehic vehicle a couple years ago uh took
out a vehicle loan on it and when I told
one of my friends about this we made a
bet that I would have it paid off by the
end of the year otherwise I would have
to call you
guys H that was a year ago uh oh and
since then I've have not paid it off
still and have also taken out a loan on
a truck as well so you you doubled down
in some strange way you're like Hey
Brother hold my beer I can make this I
can make situation way
worse a little bit a little bit hey real
quick before we dive into this what was
the other side of the BET what if what
if you have paid it off what would what
would they have to have to
done uh just kind of be okay that I had
taken out alone forame I was gonna say
really boring nowel Le cook on she's all
that like I'm just a bet all right go
ahead we're just to bet I think I got
the poor end of this thing well you well
you made the dumb you did yeah all right
so what what can we do to help now that
you have two
loans yes so I guess my question is um
is it better for me to sell both the
vehicles go out and buy a $5,000 car in
cash probably I have the one give up for
sale so the first car I owe about 7500
on what's it
worth about
15 okay and then the truck I owe 115 on
and it's worth about
14 yeah well the math on this is really
simple how much do you
make uh about uh after TA or before
taxes 60k a year so bring home
45 okay well okay so we always try to
answer these things based on what we
would do and if I'm looking at this
right here uh I'm going to
sell
um you got three I mean I'm going to I'm
going to get rid of the uh I'm trying to
get to zero here you only need one car
anyway right am I correct right I have I
have no need for two vehicles probably
sell the car and take the equity and pay
that other truck pay the truck right off
that's what I'm thinking and then you've
got a a multi-use vehicle you get 7500
on vehicle one is what I wrote down and
you only owe but it's worth 15 it's
worth 15
so yeah that's what I would do I take
that 7500 roll it into the 11 to the 115
note that you have and get it get that
thing paid off in the next four months
and then don't be a knucklehead anymore
that's what I would do it's pretty
simple stuff I mean you can do it which
it whichever way you want to but yeah
I'm selling one and paying off the other
but I want to get it done quickly and
hey I want to yeah we have a kind of a
ramsy policy if you will if you will
like just some some guidelines that the
things that you own with wheels
don't add up the to more than half of
your income you're kind of right there
is a little bitsh sort of but not
quite right yeah so yep if if they were
paid off then then I think I'd be okay
but but they're not so and even and what
I like about this conversation is it's
it's one step beneath the principles do
you need two cars no all right we sell
the car that's what I want to dive into
I'm just curious Logan not to criticize
you but I kind of want to get into to
what happened John in this situation so
it doesn't happen again cuz the good
news is you can get out of this this is
not a deep hole but I'm just curious you
got some buddies who obviously believe
like we believe no debt and they make
this bet and not only do you not pay it
off you go get another one so what was
going on in your head that led you to
buy two vehicles when you only need
one yeah that that's a good question so
the the idea all along was for me to buy
a truck um the car has been for sale now
for for a little while and the the idea
the entire time was pay that off and
then take that Equity put it into this
truck um but then this truck came up for
sale before IID had the car sold so then
I ended up with car loan on the truck
car loan on the car so you you have
trouble with with
self-control uh at times yeah yeah all
right so only way this works long term
is you're KRA you're going to find
yourself in this exact situation in a
few months cuz someone's going to say
hey man the gas prices or whatever and
you're going to think yeah I need to
keep my eyes open for just a small car
and then one's going to pop up and
you're going to like I'll get a loan out
same thing's going to happen again until
you decide I'm never going to borrow
money on a car again period yeah it's
never going to again it's it's it
becomes part of my identity it's who I
am I don't do
that and I have an 06 truck right now
that the locking mechanism doesn't work
so every time I open the car to close it
again I have to stick a pen or a key in
there I just haven't taken it to get it
fixed and dude I just I'm not gonna go
buy a new truck see what I'm saying like
because I just don't do that it's just
not a
thing yeah all right Lo that's Hey
listen you can do this first of all you
know what to do you need to do it but
the bigger issue is how did I get myself
in this mess and I'm lucky I would say
you're lucky here uh that you didn't get
into a bigger hole cuz people do this
with homes people do this with crazy
stuff1 trucks yeah I mean I could go on
and on and on how long have you had your
car for
sale uh three or four months yeah lower
the price dude yeah that's the other
issue yeah check the Kelly Blue Book and
it attractive yeah make it attractive
get underneath it get rid of the car the
burden is more important than I'm gonna
get that extra $500 or whatever who
cares sell a
car yeah all right Logan let's do this
uh are you are you you lost a bet so you
had to call the Ramsey show how familiar
are you with our baby steps and that
process oh completely I've been
listening to you guys for years I oh
okay I made some dumb decisions and I
knew it all right Hey listen there's no
shame in your game I mean that's not
what we're getting at I just was going
to give you some resources uh maybe you
know kind of get you started on every
dollar something along those lines
because if you begin to take control of
this we all have impulse control right
like
I I have to be careful how many bags of
nacho chips are in my house John I've
got to be careful about walk the pantry
if I see two or three bags or a bag
there's a real chance that I might get
into one of them late at night right so
the impulse controls so the idea is so
now I've got to set some disciplines in
place to where I go all right I
shouldn't eat after 7 o'cl right or
whatever and so this in this case you
know you got some impulse control and so
like John said I'm never going to take
out a loan again like ever and you got
to make that commitment that's a big
decision John Maxwell said this years
ago John I remember sitting there and
listening to it before I ever met him
and I'm sitting there and he talked he
was talking all these young guys young
leaders and he says make the big
decisions in life
early and then manage them the rest of
your life I love that you know well and
here and that's psychology it is but but
said it means go go Upstream what what's
going Upstream in the Coleman house we
don't I can't buy chips cuz I'm going to
eat them right I could but I don't I
don't want to fight that fight every day
I'm just not going to buy him right in
my house I'm not don't bring candy into
the house because you're going to eat
all of it you just are and yes I could
White Knuckle it and I could figure it
out I get to the bottom of what I just
don't bring in the house right similar
here if I am Logan I would go put a
freeze on my credit report so that
somebody can't just pull a report I at
least put a hurdle in front of me that
the next time I get an Impulse to go get
the car right now at least somebody's
going to stop me and say hey we can't do
this loan you need to make a phone call
and then that may be your moment right
but do some things up River to put some
hurdles in your way yeah and that's
that's what John Maxwell's talking about
that's managing those big rocks yeah
right it's so much easier isn't it when
we go I'm making this commitment and now
what do I have to do to keep this
commitment easy to not eat chips you
don't have any chips in the house right
it's true gosh I love some chips I do
too I could use some chips I'm telling
you we'll see what happens folks don't
move we got to do a couple quick uh
commercial messages you know how it
works but we're not going anywhere don't
you either this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman Dr John delone joins me
5225 this is your show America cuz we
talk about your life specifically are
you winning with your money are are you
winning in your work are you winning in
your relationships I can tell you this
if just one of those is a dumpster fire
it's going to affect the others and many
time they're all interconnected it's why
we talk about it that way and that's why
we take calls on all of those topics
would love to hear from you today 8825
5225 let's go to Detroit the Motor City
it's the Rock City Detroit Rock City
Detroit Rock well it's the Motor City
technically but I like it
how are
you hi um thank you for taking my call
um I am just wondering how to best um
support my husband in being the leader
of our home especially when it comes to
finances because he would definitely
prefer that I take the reign in pretty
much everything in our life and I know
that's really unhealthy for him and and
um I just don't know where to start are
you somebody who would let the rains
go
I I have to work really hard to con to
always try and like make him make the
decision if that makes sense yeah but
I'm not sure that you answered I don't
think you answered John's question let's
say that uh your hubs comes in today and
go hey I haven't been leading like I
ought to I'm going to take over this
this this and this what's your reaction
do you really let go I yeah or hey honey
we're gonna eat here
tonight and you go great yeah so I don't
say great but I would say sure or I
would say like hold on Mary can I jump
in as a guy who's been married 25 years
if Stacy Says sure to me I have a
follow-up question every time John am I
right hey can we eat here sure sure then
I go well where would you my immediate
reaction to that from Stacy is where do
you want to eat where would you like to
eat yeah am I right so okay yes let me
ask you this I would say I would love to
if he's offering to take me out to eat
then I would say yes to whatever he
wants okay paint me I want I want you to
step back a little bit the word lead
means a diff something different to
everybody paint me a picture of what
leadership what you want from him
specifically give me two or three things
very specifically you would like him to
take the lead on
and let you fully exhale in your home
what is
it um finances for sure okay what does
that mean him go make more money or he
pays the bills we are going shopping we
are going shopping on Saturday this is
how much we have could you please maybe
get a list together for me of what you
think is missing or what we should be
looking for so you want him to make the
shopping list and go do the
shopping um he doesn't have to make the
list but just just just basically making
a plan and committing to it okay or if
he says that we're gonna do something as
a family then being like okay this is
what we need to budget for it this is
when I want it to happen Okay instead of
just what's the next thing what's what's
another picture of leadership that you
have
um knowing knowing that let's say I need
to work so many hours in a week or he
needs to work so many hours in a week
and then like making that happen or
um we need to sell these things in the
house okay this Saturday we're going to
spend four hours just going through this
room and putting stuff on my
PL you're not talking about leadership
you're talking about like you want
someone to be engaged in your marriage
and in your
life yeah I I want to do a followup
let's go back to the second one uh he
tells me he knows how many hours he
needs to work work and he does it that
to me we got deep pretty quick there
that tells me unless I misunderstood
that tells me uh he's not being
proactive or at least you don't think
he's being proactive in working as much
I.E making as much money as he could be
is that correct or am I
wrong
um no like he
works like he works a full-time job and
he was working um an evening job because
like we really really need need the
income um but we decided that I make
more money per hour than he does and my
work is pretty flexible like I work at
part-time for an accounting firm but I
could work as many hours as I want in
the evenings so we had made the decision
that he was going to um put in his two
weeks at his evening job and then I
would work in the evenings but it keeps
turning into oh hey can we do this first
or oh hey this needs to be done and I
feel
like I don't want to be like okay I'm
ready to walk out the door as soon as he
gets home and I just leave I feel like
that's
rude okay and here's what you've said
multiple times I feel I feel I feel I
feel and I'm speaking on his
behalf you haven't sat down and said hey
you lied to
me we have those conversations okay all
right or we do I feel like you are
completely unengaged in this marriage
and in this house
unintentional right you're married to a
child and you are tired of being his mom
too or
fair right I don't want to be yes okay I
don't think that's my job you're exactly
right and every time I try and step back
we are all of a sudden three months
behind in rent or we have our accounts
been overdrawn for days in a row and
it's like where did the money go oh
you're supposed to be working oh but you
as like so I keep trying to work more
but I also we also have two young kids
yeah have you sat down with him and said
honey I'm I'm I'm am scared to my
bones after the after the live stream
what does he say um he apologizes okay
and then we have the same
conversation you know what do you what
do you know about his what do you know
about his background why what what do
you think tell John what you think is
going on running his life gotcha he grew
up with his mom running his life so so
we could say and I'm I'm I'm not trying
to hang something on this guy but we're
talking to his wife John is it
immaturity feel like this is extremely
immature situation yes and where I have
no compassion for him like just as a guy
who works really hard to be a good
husband and be a good dad and to work
really hard at my job like I don't have
I get not having compassion there on the
other side I have great compassion for a
guy who simply opens up his tool to kit
to help out when he has a wife saying
I'm
scared I need your help and he looks in
his toolkit and there's no Tools in
there yeah and that's why the reason I
ask you to be very specific is this
doesn't feel sexy it doesn't feel
romantic it doesn't feel like Hollywood
said it was doesn't feel like the
notebook but he may need some very clear
guidance I need you to do this yeah and
if you've already done that and he
looked at you and remember behavior is a
language if he either said these words
or acted these words I don't really care
what makes you feel safe I'm I don't
really care I'm not going to do that
then you have to stop doing the same
thing over and over expecting a
different result you have to choose
reality and reality is I am married to a
guy that does not care about his wife or
his kids he cares
about yeah yeah and well he lives like
he lives he he lives more like by his
emotions so like if we have a
conversation or or like I have a
meltdown a breakdown in front of him and
he has a conversation then he apologizes
and he goes into what I call like the
puppy dog stage yep where he's like
nervous about everything he said well
and that's that's why I started this
whole call I started this whole call
hours I started the whole call asking
you is he allowed to lead in his own
home do you have do you lead do you live
by your emotions too and Leadership for
you means you never feel scared or
uncomfortable or sad or tired because if
that's what leadership is for you it it
doesn't
exist if you talk sorry I don't
understand what you're asking I'm saying
if leadership means I want a man that I
never feel sad or scared or worried
about money or frustrated or tired
that's not leadership that's fantasy
it's not real if you want if you want a
co-parent and a co- uh partner if you
want that and you want him to take the
lead on some things yeah man that's all
in you got to be very very specific and
if he looks at you and says I can't do
this and tell him I don't want a puppy
dog I don't want oh I'm okay I'm asking
you I need you to do these things and
then if he chooses not to then you have
to live in that reality and I'd go see a
counselor ASAP got to right away hey
Austin hooked him up with one of our
financial coaches to get this process
started this is the
[Music]
range
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman Dr John deloney joins me we're
here for you this hour
8825 5225 let's go to the City of Angels
Los Angeles California Christine joins
us there Christine how can we
help hi oh wow um how are you guys well
we're having a blast how are you you you
handle it deep breath ready to go we're
here to
help um I'm good hi so um I'm 31 I'm
married um I have a daughter me and my
husband have been listening for about
like five months now we're on baby step
number two with 14,000 in credit card
debt um now my question isn't with that
um my question is actually I decided to
go back to school nursing
school um and private school will be
around like
$70,000 and it'll be done in two years
but also there's another choice of like
Community College but'll it'll be done
with like 3 to five years depending on
how fast I do it how much will that cost
it's going to be around like less than
15,000 so it' be
15,000 and tell me what the difference
five years yeah but three to five based
on how much you can do so do you know
what would have to be uh what the hours
would be let's just say on a week or a
month in order to get done in 3 years at
15K what would that require of you
TimeWise that's actually like um the
good thing about the community college
is because they have night classes so I
can still work in the morning and like
do at least three to four classes every
semester well and would that get you
done in three
years I bet Christine you can do it
faster is this is a no- break here's why
private schools often will put you in
what they call a cohort and it's very
prescribed every every hour is written
out for you everybody does the same
class in the same order at the same time
and a community college feels more um it
feel it's more like it's like a buffet
come get what you want when you want it
and they're going to tell you it's going
to take about three to five years
because that's the average it takes
somebody who's taken two classes at a
time maybe a third class and then I got
to drop back to one class cuz I got a
kid that's sick and so it takes about
three to five years I started actually
do
what uh that's how I started I actually
already started with Community College
with one class okay well listen the the
course load to to ler is the
same yeah okay so that means you can do
this in two years you just have to
follow that that level of curriculum
that it would take you would be doing in
the private school just taking the right
amount of classes at the right time or
take it do it in three years and and get
on with your life right Christine I I'm
I wonder if this if this is not about
the money because you just had already
thought this through as soon as I said
well is it possible for you for your
family for your day job to do this you
were like oh yeah well I could do this
this this three night so you've already
run this through so are you are you is
there a deeper concern that you have as
it relates to time what it's more the
time of like it being 3 to 5 years or
like 2 years just finish it they'll do
it like you know they already have the
set schedule for you but also the money
that I'll be missing because I'll be
part-time at my work so you're going to
have to be part-time to do the private
school option private yeah but my point
is I think that's off the table and I
think you know that when you called I
think you were leaning towards Community
College except you were like oh is it
going to take longer my point is uh do
you remember the last time you saw a
nurse
yourself uh a nurse I work in hospice
okay but I'm saying I want you the last
time you were a patient and a nurse
worked with you do you remember
that yes okay did you ask the nurse
where she went to
school actually yes okay what'd she say
she went to community college did she
kill you did did you all of a sudden
judge her because of that yeah she
started jabbing you with needles all
willy-nilly and crazy all right that's
my point no no she was amazing she was
amazing let me tell you something
Christine this is very simple this is a
conversation with your husband to look
at what is life going to look like to
knock this out in two to three years to
John's point I got to take x amount of
night classes to knock it out quickly
I'm saving a lot of money by doing this
it's just going to cost me time can we
do this hubs is on board your child your
daughter how old is
she she's six six she has no concept of
time she's going to be fine uh this is a
family meeting about time
and how our family's going to have to
adjust to this because from the money
standpoint this is not even a
conversation well I I get College all
the way well hold on so but Christine is
I somebody told you this math they said
hey you're going to make 85,000 as a
nurse here in Los Angeles or 100 yeah
and if you get done one year faster
you're going to make about 55 or 60,000
more well that's how much you're paying
extra to go to private school so why
don't you just get it done
where that falls on its head is you are
paying the private school
$60,000 to force you to get this done in
two years just do it yourself yeah save
$60,000 remove the stupid tax everybody
else buys thatly the story you knew do
what you knew the story that someone
told me it would be of course they did
they the lost wages and all yeah that's
fair but that's not your case now if you
fart around and do like one class and
then one class and then your kid a
suddenly 11 or 12 and you have two
classes left and it's 5 years yeah but
that's on you I'm not going to pay a
school $660,000 to force me into to do
something just got to go do it yeah it's
a marketing message Christine there's a
reason why all those colleges have
really big and nice
buildings because they charge lots and
lots of dollars and they know how to
Market it yeah they got a compelling
conversation in their head that they've
tested and it works on you so we just
deconstructed it but use your common
sense here this is awesome you're going
to be a nurse quicker than you think
fantastic uh you're going to save
$60,000 oh my gosh I mean just the it's
mind-blowing to me it's mindblowing just
absolutely crazy uh all right let's go
to James in Cincinnati James how can we
help hey guys thanks for taking my call
Ken John you bet good to hear from you
so like a lot of callers I'm in am
mountain of debt um I'm 40 years old I'm
behind on my retirement goal that I that
I hope to achieve someday
and I have an opportunity to double my
income I work remotely and currently
have a job and I have an opportunity to
take a second job on top of that so I'm
looking for advice on you know do I do
it do I pull the trigger and say yes to
that what would be the reason why you
wouldn't do it knowing that you're in a
lot of debt and behind on your
retirement
goals right I don't have one then it's a
pretty simple answer it's called bigger
shovel Dave Ramsey talked about that for
a long time more income management and
stress calendar management stress be the
only kind of downfall which is why I
asked you what would be the reason not
to do it is that a big fear or can that
be
managed I hope so well no no we don't
hope so but also but you're you're
stressed right now with how much you owe
and how behind you are so it's it's
stress versus stress is three years of
this is going to suck is that worth um
the rest of your life the back 45 years
of your life to be free if not cool
well let me kind of paint a picture then
I've got a seven-year-old I've got a
baby on the way in April my wife's not
going to work when the baby comes yep um
and I'm I'm looking at probably 13
months and we'll be free yes this a Nob
brainer this is absolutely every day of
the week and twice on Sunday you say yes
to this second job your wife's going to
be home to take care of the kids you're
fine you'll be tired you'll be okay but
this is this is a no-brainer you have to
do this your seven-year-old will turn
eight and not have any memory of this
and your newborn won't remember any of
it and your wife will say thank God I
have a man who went and did what we had
to do so that I could stay home with
this
baby that's a breath of fresh air I
appreciate you and by the way James will
this be fun no will it be terrible yes
will you be mad halfway through oh it'll
be furious do it anyway yeah do it
anyway you're you're going to exchange
the stress of debt I like how you put
this for a stress of activity for
instance uh I was working out last night
I'm in a new routine John and I'm not
going to lie to you I hate this part of
it hate it it sucked really bad yep felt
great an hour later of sitting at home
told my wife I go H feel pretty good
yeah I did not feel that way in the
middle of the routine of that that
workout so you it's what you're getting
on the other side here James so buckle
up this is going to change your life
forever absolutely yes yes and yes good
man way a step up love it congrats by
the way on the new one the little one
that's going to be a lot of fun and
Boyer you're going to be setting that
child up for a great future as a result
of this 13-month grind that's how you're
looking at this John deloney great James
Childs our fearless leader thank you and
the crew for keeping us on the air and
you America for listening this is the
ramsy
[Music]
show
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions this is the Ramsey show is
where we help you win in your life with
your money in your relationships and in
your work 8825 5225
8825 5225 that's the number to jump in
on the conversation Dr John deloney
joins me I'm Kim Coleman we are with you
taking you along on the ride the next
hour so how can we help jump in I
promise you there is hope and we're
going to help you see it let's get to
Lexington South Carolina Ken is there
well now this is cantastic we have a Ken
on the line talking to a Ken John it's
the year of Ken wow there's no way you
went cantastic on us K James taught me
that one Ken how are you I'm doing good
how about yourselves a pleasure to be
here well it's our pleasure to talk to
you how can we help
today well you guys my heart's pounding
I I'm a huge fan of you guys so um I'm
gonna get right to it I am in a
relationship with a beautiful young
woman she is you know just absolutely
amazing um both of us ever since she's
been in my life has been going to church
with me um but I struggle a little bit
with my own selfworth I I feel like if
I'm not able to do um certain things for
her be able to do you know by her the
nice things you know and all that stuff
I feel like I'm failing as you know her
um as her significant other this is a
woman that I want to spend the rest of
my life with um and I plan on you know
making that happen at some point in time
in our life but I struggle a lot with
not feeling like I'm enough as far as my
income and stuff like that what do you
do Ken and what do you make I am a I'm a
truck driver uh and I I'm local to my
area and I make roughly I'm hourly now
so I make roughly about gross probably
about 75 a year okay well let's start
with this okay $75,000 is a very good
income and if you look at um well let me
let me put this way I could hear the
ticktockers now it's not a great income
I understand inflation where it is but
$75,000 is has been a threshold for many
many decades in research where people
say they achieve a certain level of
Happiness so you're no dud that's all I
want to get to and I know John's going
to dig in as to why you've got this
worth issue but let's just say that
financially you're no dud 75,000 driving
a truck locally and I would also say
that you are nowhere near uh have if you
nowhere near Reaching Your Potential as
it relates to what you can make you have
more financial growth so you're not a
dud and you have more potential and I
want you to hear that and that's the
truth that's not a that's not a RR
speech that's just based on the numbers
and what you've done to this point and
what that experience could allow you to
do in the future do you understand what
I'm saying absolutely I appreciate that
but do you believe that because it's not
a Ross spee do you believe that you can
make more than 75 in the future I do
believe that I I just think that with
some things that that happened in my
past sure I I struggled because I did
have a you know a digital marketing
business that I tried to start and then
right after I got my LLC back Co hit and
then it just completely tanked so I
pretty much just gave up on that which I
probably shouldn't have but you know no
maybe maybe you should have yeah brother
who
man who told you when you were real
little that you always did it
wrong all right so it it was not my
family um my family has always been very
supportive as a matter of fact whenever
I went through my extreme dark Valley
that I got that I got into in
2022 um they were there to support me it
was actually my previous marriage okay
that made me feel like I was not yeah
there we go there we go yeah so here's
what I want you to do and what I'm G
what I'm gonna say is gonna sound cheesy
and it's gonna you're going to roll your
eyes and I want you to actually go do it
will you have your word do I have your
word you'll do it absolutely absolutely
it's a lot of trust Ken I got to tell
you I don't know what he's going to say
I want you to swing by Home Depot or
Lowe's oh I like where this is going I
don't want you to buy two brand new um
cinder blocks okay okay I want you to
take them
home and I want you to put some duct
tape on them and get a magic marker like
a black Sharpie and I want you to write
on that duct
tape a few of the
sentences that your ex-wife used to stab
you
with you're too fat you're you're lazy
Are you seriously this is what you
think's dinner I want you to write that
stuff down on there and then I want you
to write down on the other
one some of the things you said to you
as your digital marketing business was
falling apart and
failing I knew we couldn't do this this
sucks this I man she was right I want
you to write that stuff down okay and
then here's the exercise I want you to
set set a stopwatch for about 20 minutes
or 30 minutes or you don't even have to
set a watch I want you to pick up those
bricks and I want you just to start
making laps around your backyard like a
crazy
person until your forearms burn until
you can't physically hold them anymore
till your hands start to
ache and I want you to go in the back
far corner of your backyard and throw
them on the ground and literally say I'm
never carrying this
again okay cuz what you're doing is
you're allowing your ex wife to have
access to your new
relationship you're allowing the fact
that you got in the ring like all great
boxers and got knocked down like all
boxers do you're allowing that knock
down to Define your next
fight and you're just carrying these
cinder blocks around with you 247 365
and you're not solving the past the past
happened what you're doing is making
sure you can't be successful moving
forward enough is enough is enough
enough you're worth more than that dude
absolutely I appreciate that man is that
fair that is fair let me ask you this
really quick what do you want to do what
do you think about well come on it's
funny that you asked that because I kind
of anticipated this question being asked
being that I've watched almost or
listened to every episode almost on
Apple podcast um and that's just genu
genuinely direction that you go um but I
want to help men who went through stuff
like what I went through um I used to be
a social media influencer I actually had
a half a million followers at one point
in time and when I when I separated I
get I got rid of it all I didn't want to
I didn't want to be a part of it no more
I felt like it was just another burden
um my big my biggest platform was Tik
Tok so I know how the Tik Tock Al
algorithm goes um and I I I now have a
program that I actually started and I
want men to be able to get the help that
they need and have that
accountability U that they that they're
speaking so that they can be bigger and
better for their family hey K before you
before you pop in real quick though I
got to get out something else okay get
it go ahead well Ken I'm talking to you
Ken and Lexington you have no business
teaching men yet until you can walk the
walk
Fair absolutely okay uh okay yes and no
uh here's what I think uh wounded people
help other wounded people in the
battlefield if you can drag somebody off
and here's where I'm going with this I'm
not going to try to turn this into a
business yet I'm not putting that on you
Ken I don't want you to feel it but
here's what I do want you to feel if
it's getting back on Tik Tok and just
being transparent and bleeding and let
people know what you've learned about
yourself and and what you uh have walked
through and how you're getting on the
other side if that helps one man do that
and here's why I'm telling you that John
telling that John I want Ken to get some
victories I want him to see some little
WIS that no matter how bad he's been
hurt damaged whatever you're useful yeah
I think being useful is what he needs to
do right now this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
welcome back to the ramsy show Dr John
deloney joins me I'm Ken Coleman we're
Ramsey personalities and we are your
co-host today on the ramsy showle
8825 5225 is the number uh it's time for
our question of the day the Ramsey Show
question of the day is brought to you by
neighborly your hub for Home Services in
case you're a new listener what does
that mean exactly by the way John if I
was a new listener and I had my lack of
home uh handyman talent I wouldn't know
what Home Services what what is that I
have no idea thank God for neighborly uh
they're a family of locally operated
Home Services providers who are
dedicated to helping the Stacy Coleman
of the world survive they survive their
marriages to call because I mean I can't
fix anything thankfully I can call and
go check out neighborly you can start
your search today at neighbor.com Ramsey
all right I got to say I read through
this question early oh you did I'm real
excited about this question okay I
haven't read it I think it can uh we
might even disagree on it but I think oh
that's fun it has to burn my saddle all
right today's question comes from Alexa
in Iowa my husband and I are on baby
step two and bring home around $120,000
a year we have
$230,000 in consumer student loan and
solar panel debt yes a whole lot of
stupid my husband is a mechanic and has
taken on side jobs in his home shop
which provides extra income I am a CPA
and would love to take on side
bookkeeping and payroll work however my
office has the policy that we can't do
that kind of work outside the office for
ourselves because they say that would
take away from the other employees I'm
struggling to find something that I can
do remotely in the financial space that
wouldn't conflict with my office policy
should I talk to my boss or HR
department to see what options are
available or oh this is the magic
question is it none of their business
what I do outside of my business
hours okay uh I would talk to the boss
or HR department to ask for more clarity
on said policy and gently and
respectfully keep asking questions as to
why we have the policy and how the
policy affects her situation and the
reality of that because policies to me
should always be guidelines and allow
the leader flexibility or else we get
stupid crazy ideas like you have to wear
your mask until you sit at the table and
so my point is like meaning meaning that
no matter where you fall on that you
kind of have to go that doesn't make
sense and I'm not taking a position on
that but it's like what so I that
irritates me and I I don't know what you
think about this what I'm going to say
maybe you're surprised by this but uh I
would say it is a caseby casee basis
okay on what a
business can dictate to me outside of
this
place I'm going to say Case by case
that's probably fair cuz my my knee jerk
my kneer reaction
is you you hired me to do a job I agreed
to do that job yeah when I go
home that's my home I agree with that
part right I think she should be able to
do this and whatever I need to do to
help out my family per our situation
right as long as you're not competing or
you're in any way uh I'm not using
resour comp right yeah and I think like
so if I have if I'm a mechanic and I
take your tools to my house to do work
you can't do that good right I agree um
but if you say hey if you come work here
and fix cars here you're allowed to fix
any other car anywhere right that feels
like an overreach it is you and I agree
on that one so when I said Case by case
that's but you and I we can't go like I
couldn't go take a gig I can't go
publish a book with another publisher I
signed a contract Case by that's right
that's right I think Common Sense has to
rule the day and I don't believe a
company's own people yes and that
irritates me so let me be clear on this
yeah this pisses me off it makes me mad
okay I'm with you okay okay same team
the way she worded it if she worded it
properly it doesn't even make sense uh
if I we can't do work out that kind of
work bookkeeping and payroll work
outside the office for ourselves because
they say it would take away from other
place what are you talking about here's
what here's what that means that makes
no sense she is capped on how many
clients she can get during the workday
so she goes and gets their other clients
and what the business is saying is whoa
whoa whoa if you can go get other
clients you need to send them to us so
we can give them to these other people
oh yeah no all clients are our clients
yeah you know what that's called
Monopoly thinking do you know what the
federal government thinks about
monopolies they break them up that's
right and by the way I agree yeah with
so this is
nonsensical this is again I don't want
to go on a rant it's just bad
leadership policies shouldn't be laws
yes so let me give you a good example um
I was having something delivered
irritates me and to my house and I live
out in the country on a long uh gravel
driveway and they said hey we can't
deliver to your
house and I said okay great um can you
bring it to the
office and they said well the policy is
we're not allowed to deviate from the
delivery the Final Destination we wrote
it in a
contract I said what's the option then
it's like well you wait at the bottom
and it's about a quarter mile driveway
you wait at the bottom between the hours
of 1 and 5 and we'll drop it off I say
so I have to just sit out there in my
truck for 5 hours
like um yeah they didn't think through
that and I said can you just drop it off
what's the policy I said can you just
drop it in my house well we can't
because that's the policy and I said so
you've created a world where you can't
deliver the thing that you told the yeah
the the person and it got real quiet
they said we'll call you back right
right because there wasn't able we
weren't able to think outside the policy
towards what makes sense to get this guy
the thing he ordered right but let's
keep going beautiful example but not
only is the policy nonsensical
it keeps Common Sense from happening
right to where the person on the phone
should have went all right here's the
deal I'll just call Herb when he comes
back tomorrow he'll drive he's going to
drop in your truck at your office she
she or he whoever's on the phone with
you doesn't even have the ability to
solve the problem because of the policy
right and that's up Joo talks about that
that's decentralized leadership right
that's only this person up here can make
the decision and all of yall run out and
make my decision for me yeah um which
turns your entire organization into a
bunch of admins
instead of a bunch of thinkers and
leaders and this is how common sense
becomes
uncommon and that's where we are in
today's world because we are we are
operating off of policies not
principles let let's let me let me
attack something you don't think I'm
going to attack this is going to be fun
you ready read an article today James I
should have sent it to you but here we
go the federal government the amount of
debt that each the last two or three
years as a congressional budget office
the amount of debt that we are
accumulating as a country is an absolute
runaway freight train that is on fire
and that is policy thinking not
principle thinking so I'm attacking
everybody in DC so that way everyone's
offended and I don't get but but it's
true when when policy is well we got to
do this piece of legislation here we got
to put this pork barrel we got to give
this money here this money and it's like
uh the house is on fire yeah we don't
balance our budget we all get out of the
house well we have to follow the exit
plan we got to have a policy for this we
got to have a our policy says we got to
do this and both
parties both parties and F this is
fiscal here I'm talking about our nation
is so crazy in debt it is the dollar is
is in danger you're talking about this
is how Nations crumble and I'm not
trying to freak people out John I'm just
saying it's wild we we got a fiscal
problem this is a money show yes and all
we talk about is well hold on we got to
do it the right way we got to the policy
yeah and so anyway I'm making a a
greater point to say oh shove the policy
this lady needs to actually I'm going to
go back to the last part of it John
here's what I think tell me if I'm wrong
and I mean this I don't think she talks
to HR I think she just goes and starts
doing it I think she just starts
offering the services if it gets back to
him she goes your policy was restricting
my ability to go earn money that's about
as anti-American and anti-common sense
as anything I've ever heard is that am I
over the am over the line if there is a
clear what I don't want to do is Cash in
her Integrity right I don't think that's
an Integrity issue she civil
disobedience is what I'm crying okay am
I
wrong I don't think I don't think I feel
like I'm making you a little
uncomfortable no I like it I'm thinking
do it real fast cuz the music's coming
up I I like the idea in principle I
think they would have a right to fire
her if she violates the policy that's
fair fair I won't fight that yeah um but
I do think there has to be a group of
people who say hey can we do the right
thing by people outside of the policy
please I say go make the money and if
they give you a hard time I think it was
a Johnny Paycheck song Take This Job and
Shove It This is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
a
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm kid
Coleman Dr John deloney joins me 8825
5225 is the phone number
5225 let's go to Charlotte in Cleveland
Ohio Charlotte how can we
help hi it's an honor to talk to you
guys oh thank you it's our honor what's
going
on so I'm having a good problem um so my
husband just found out that he's gonna
be getting two substantial bonuses from
his work and I'm just feeling a little
overwhelmed with what to do um we don't
currently have a financial adviser but I
just am terrified to make a mistake okay
but I also feel
uncomfortable in that realm um it just
seems like sometimes
there's it feels kind of like the car
salesman attitude like a little like
yeah you've seen too many movies too
many TV shows and my guess is you
haven't sat down with a real financial
adviser and had a conversation with them
where everything they said made sense
and you felt like oh I can make a
decision is that
fair yeah I I go every two weeks to my
local Charles Schwab to do myself 401K
that's not what we're talking that's not
what we're talking I'm talking about a
advisor you know uh okay so answer
John's question how much money is this
yeah um so this year it's like 150,000
and next year it's G to be like half a
million dollars okay did you grow up
with
much no okay so in your mind and really
will go all the way to your nervous
system in your body other people make
that kind of money not
us yeah we've always we done the Dave
thing we've been Grinders is what we
call it and we're not bad now like we're
worth like probably like half a million
now but we've we've really like worked
and all of a sudden it's like just like
plop in our laps and I don't know do you
have any debt
weird no we're um five four five and six
okay so how much do you have left on the
house um probably about 250 okay so you
you've been listening to Dave for a long
time
yes yeah we got married at 22 and I am
29 now so you tell me you tell me what
you think Dave would say to you if he
knew you were going to come into
$650,000 over the next two years above
and beyond your normal income if I
understood you correctly is that
correct yeah okay what would he say to
do with that
money uh pay the house off all right so
there's one thing right so yes so we
knock the house out with with this bonus
money and who's doing baby step four
who's guiding you through baby step four
15% of your income to retirement who's
doing that you at shop on your
own yeah we've just been kind of doing
it ourselves just because we can't okay
I can't figure out the whole fee thing
and problem index funds that's the
problem it's it's it's it's you
shouldn't be figuring out how to do that
uh I don't want to figure out how to
build a house I want to hire a great
contractor who's built lots of houses
and has a great track record so
Charlotte you've been around us enough
to know what a smart Vestor Pro is these
are men and women that have been vetted
by our team and in Cleveland Ohio
there's probably more than a handful a
lot of them and you can get to ramsy
solutions.com and let's just pick five
okay or three and set up appointments
with them have a meeting with them look
them in the eye do you like them was one
a little bit weird was one a little
aggressive was one really super amazing
whatever the idea is and Dave has told
people this for decades you need to get
someone that you feel like you got a
good connection with that's a b does a
really good job of explaining all this
stuff that you're scratching your head
on in the Schwab office and you get to
the point where you understand okay this
is the between a Roth this is the back
door Roth this is an IRA this is what
I'm going to do with my 401k and you get
to understand all of it and explain it
to you until you get to the point where
you go okay I want to do that and I want
to do that and you know why and you have
the common sense you've got a lot of
discipline you guys can figure this out
but that's what you need to do so that
you have a plan Beyond paying off the
house what are we going to do with this
windfall of income when we look at baby
step five how much more would we need to
put in there to the kids we think that
the the nest egg is where it needs to be
over the next X amount of years the
smart Vestor Pro is going to walk
through that with you and all of a
sudden you realize you're completely in
control and I think that's what you're
scared
of yeah that makes sense John so you
didn't you didn't like that answer why
didn't you like that
[Laughter]
answer I just I don't know I just I I'm
like a pretty like plan like follow the
plan kind of person and it just I don't
know what to do like baby step seven is
just so like wide open and it almost
felt like something was taken away from
me like the plan I think you're a
control freak I I well I think you've
had to have control in your life to
survive
Fair that's fair and so that same that
same action that kept you alive all
those years is going to choke the joy in
life out of this amazing work you and
your husband have put in to change your
family
tree yeah and so there comes a moment
when you stop being gazelle intense when
you stop running for your life and then
you start building something
amazing and listen you're going to have
to practice that because you've never
done it before what is that
mean you have to look in the mirror and
go we're going to have a paid off house
and both of our kids college funded
fully and we're gonna have a couple
hundred, left
over and let's go to a really nice
dinner right you're gonna have you're
GNA be able to do some things and you're
going to realize it didn't just solve
your marriage it didn't just fix
everything this is going to be a slow
walk um like into a new kind of Life
I'll tell you the things that have
transformed my life and these are
conversations offline with Dave just
private he's a buddy of mine and talking
about coming from a uh East Tennessee
kid without a lot he said dude I still
to this day have to look at the ratios
because the numbers are
crazy so I have to look at the ratios
yes this car that I can now afford with
cash a thousand times over cost this
much what is it in relationship to how
much I gave
what is it relationship to my salary so
somebody old you may have said $50,000
for a car are you crazy new you might
say $50,000 is like me buying a $10,000
car five years ago we're good and we
also increased our giving that much too
see what I'm saying you're going to have
to practice this new identity and it's
okay yeah we definitely want to give and
it's I think it is like the whole like
lifestyle piece we live very frugally
keep living frugally but do something
fun yeah go on a trip with someone man
right you have to get out of your head
that only they are
successful because now they is
you yeah you're successful
too and you used to have some judgments
about they and now you're gonna have to
let some of that go because you know
that y'all are a pretty good pretty good
couple pretty amazing
people yeah Grinders you know those
little buckets that we had at Ramsay for
a while for the kids I don't know what
the latest product is but this a give
little like a a little container give
save spend so what you do with this
money is very simple give
some save a bunch spend
some Tada okay you get
that okay yeah you get to decide because
you're debt free give save Spin and yes
you've been you've been holding on to
the Rope for your whole life you're 29
you're about to be 30 and you're about
to be a millionaire and then you realize
the Rope runs
out right so you're GNA have to practice
that unsteady feeling for a while it
should feel weird for a while that's all
right you're a millionaire you know what
may be fun John and I don't know if this
tell me if this makes sense
psychologically it's almost like she
should pick something to give to First
yep get her out of the before she even
thinks about her and her husband and
saving and spending like just go bless
somebody like blow their mind some of
this take care of somebody that you
don't know that well or somebody's kind
of on the periphery ask your pastor if
they know of a family go give and also
put one nice thing out there that you're
going to go get it's time for my husband
to get a car that actually works right
it's time for me to get a new washing
machine that doesn't leak all over the
like whatever the thing is put those
things on paper and then call yourself a
smart Vester Pro go to ramsy
solutions.com
smartvestor and they'll get you hooked
up they'll teach you and they'll get you
squared away Charlotte congratulations
you guys have lived like no one else and
now you're about ready to live and give
like no one else this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman Dr John deloney joins me the
phone number is triple 8825
5225 and we're going to take your calls
but we're going to do something a little
bit different this is fun uh I want you
to talk about it John um I don't know
how long ago it was now cuz time is like
the older I get I I don't if it was
yesterday or three years ago but you
came up with a great idea to take on
this loneliness and and and disconnected
society that we have and you came up
with a great idea that became a runaway
hit and now it's got 73 editions it's
got 95 Edition Oh see it keeps going and
uh this is really cool and so we're
going to play off of this but I want you
to just give us 30 seconds on what it is
and then we're GNA do something we've
never done on the show before the the
short of it is um I was talking to a
buddy of mine asking him what people
were struggling with out in the real
world because I was working in in
education and he said uh I've been
listening to you for a while deloney me
and my wife we put all our screens away
all our phones and iPads and now me and
my daughters are just sitting in the
living room staring at each other and I
was like well talk to them and he goes
okay I'll just talk to him and then the
light bulb went off and I said oh you
don't know how yeah like it's a skill
set right and so it was as simple as I'm
going to give you some prompts and the
results I'm getting credit the Halo
credit of people actually talking again
without phones communicating with one
another having fun laughing crying
whatever and it's the questions for
humans man questions for humans we're
going to do a questions for humans
segment here and James is going to
surprise us yeah so James you're gonna I
guess you take over we're just now
you're you're hosting yeah so I picked a
few that are kind of fun and
light-hearted and then some that are a
little more serious so boy we'll start
with the am I going to cry I don't know
all right the first Decks that you did
were like real you know like what's your
favorite poop joke and now they've
gotten real real heartfelt and serious
right I've had to grow up in this in
this radio job so first question is for
John uh yeah maybe John and then you can
answer it too so what is hands down the
best book movie or show of last year oh
of last year or this year like just re
the past
year oh my goodness the
um I don't know man what's the best book
of last year I'm trying to think I'm
trying to think I read going through all
three categories for what like what am I
passionate about say say is book album
and what book movie or show book movie
or show of the last year for
you or it could be one that you you
consumed last year it didn't have to
come out last
year yeah this is some great radio we're
put on there okay I I'll jump in for for
me it's the uh Yellowstone spin-off
series 1883 and
1923 I I can't remember the last time
well I can last time I enjoyed a
television show that much uh was Friday
Night Lights uh I thought those two
shows fantastic loved them absolutely
loved them only murders in the building
my wife and I got hooked on Seas 1 2 and
we that show is a masterpiece there we
go we unlocked him there there you go I
like all those those are great all right
this one is for you guys if you two had
to buy a plane ticket right now for for
a guys trip together where would you go
there's no way we'll ever come to
consensus cuz I think we're wildly
different in our like that's what makes
it so fun you got you got to me okay
I'll say it's a it's a tropical
situation where there is pickle ball
golf Spa you know ocean sand that's me
can I tell you where my heart went Ken
where I want to go to Normandy I want
you to walk me through it like if I
could have Ken walk me through like the
history of these places I think every
American should visit wow and I don't
know anything about it James has been
with me in DC I got to experience Ken
and DC and I got to tell you dormy that
would be epic he comes impressive boy I
feel really shallow after that exchange
that's cool get hey I'd get a tropical
massage with you too Caribbean pickle
ball versus D-Day just that's it well
two very different trips but both
rewarding there you go all right what
did you spend way too much money on in
the last year oh oh easy pickle ball
paddle I went to to a local Lodge before
a hunting trip and I said I'm need you
to make sure I'm not uh cold and I said
I'm giving you a blank check dude and he
came back and we went to the
register easily the most expensive know
whato purchase I've ever made in my life
by a 100 mile suits dress boots
everything I'm picturing Jim car's
character and dumb and dumber when they
finally make it to Colorado I mean dude
I've got hunting gear that
I hope my son gets married in it because
it's going to be way more expensive than
any tux but I overspent to that by a lot
now see I spent more than just that I
want to clarify my answer but you said
overspend it's like there's a reasonable
number for said item but there are some
things I spent way more money on but I
went I didn't overpay that was worth it
oh I way overpaid inquiring minds want
to know what kind of pickle ball
padal uh Jula yeah it was I don't know
but Zack over here and I bought Sitka
the greatest hunting gear on planet
Earth yeah I love it all right what are
two do one or two of your New Year's
resolutions this year I don't do
resolutions I have a have a fundamental
stance against them my kid you not
because all the data behind it John
probably knows even more about this than
I do from the psychology side of things
but they just miserably fail and so I
read that about five or six years ago
and uh so I have a I have a plan I have
a year plan for myself and then my wife
and I and and and and so it's it's not
resolutions they're just like this is
where we're trying to get to we got some
destinations are there any highlights of
stuff that you want to share I know
that's uh
highlights yeah we want to do something
really cool I don't want to share it
over the air but there's a trip that we
we really really want to do and I know
Stacy would not be comfortable with me
describing that but yeah is it a pickle
ball trip yes uh it's tropical massages
I will tell you that I will look for a
pickleball court at said trip but yeah
stuff like that financial goals so we we
said how much do we want to invest this
year what are we giving where that kind
of stuff I don't get into the whole uh
I'm going to do dry January or and I'm
the opposite I've got you have a bunch
of resolu resolutions like give us one
in concrete give me top two the two big
ones are number one and this is going to
sound cheesy James and you're going to
roll your eyes I'm being dead serious CU
you'll know cuz you and I worked
together a lot very nervous I want to be
come more likable um and I would say
delightful I want people when I walk
into the room people don't go oh God I
want them to go hey I want everyone's
disposition and I know that I come
around with a heavy energy I'm always
having heavy conversations did you read
this you know about dopamine and it
wears people out and so this year I want
to be a more joyful presence when I walk
in a room that's number one I want to be
delightful and number two I want to be
on time it's been a tough January which
goes toward the number one it helps with
number one people aren't instantly mad
when I walk in 9 minutes late right
that's good um there's an incredible
woman out in the audience that we had a
meeting with earlier and I was late to
that meeting so there we go that's how
good we're doing that's probably a good
resolution I could add but you get my
point I I want bigger goals so that it
requires a lot of inertia well and so
for me to be more joyful that means I
got to pay ATT to go to bed I got to eat
right I got to quit eating so much junk
food I got I would say yours are legit
to the point that I don't even that's
way heavier and bigger than a resolution
and that's why I like I want a
press 200 yeah I see what you're saying
oh resolutions to me I hear it's always
I want to stop doing this I like that
yours was I want to grow I want to
become yeah the research says if you
want to stop a thing that's pretty
limited because usually you want to stop
a thing because you don't like you and
so you're stopping a thing out of
dislike for yourself it never works yeah
if you want to become something new now
you're on to something yeah yeah you got
time for more yeah this one's maybe
related maybe not so in what area of
Life do you think you'll need the most
help over the next 12
months Ken could use some hygiene help
I'm just kid
ah I'm going to need help on uh being on
time I'm going to need help on being a
joyful presence I'm have to practice
this because it's not my natural
disposition I'm just kind of uh kind of
make you like like some like principles
or like help with that or you just like
do you have something that's helping you
become more likable or you just kind of
taking a stab at it uh yeah I've got a
couple things it's it's a little too
personal for the air but um but I do
have asked a few people to just point it
out just pointed out when you're when I
have heavy energy in a room yeah are you
open to the YouTube commenters helping
you out nope BR YouTubers all come on
help out that' be great that' be
great I I tell you I need help
navigating this next season in the next
year when my my oldest son goes
away I'm not trying to bring us down I'm
just saying that's new territory for me
and I know my heart's going to hurt
really really bad and uh but it's
natural healthy and it needs to happen
so anyway I think I need to talk to some
dudes who been through that and it'll be
good but I think that's going to be
weird so that's going to be tough way to
bring down a room James thanks hey that
was that was good guys that was
excellent that was great stuff thank you
Dr John deloney for that fabulous series
you can get it at Rams exclusive.com all
397 editions of conversations with
[Music]
humans
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions this is the Ramsey Show it's
where we help people win in their life
specifically with their money their
relationships and their work
8825 5225 is the phone number you can
jump in I'm Ken Coleman Dr johnone joins
me this hour
8825 5225 let's get right to it Mobile
Alabama is where Anthony Waits Anthony
how can we help hey Ken and John how are
y'all today we're having a blast what's
going on with you oh I just uh I'm
sitting at the apex of the Seesaw and I
do not know which way to go love that
analy uh I'm right here about six months
away from being 62 and I cannot decide
to retire or work another year or
two okay so let's just start with where
are you leaning right now we're not
holding you to this but if you had to
decide today or five minutes ago did it
change where are you
leaning um leaning towards retirement
all right and so what is making you
question that to the point that you
would call us to get our
take uh I've been doing it since 14 and
scared to death scared to death to stop
y I hear it how are you doing
financially paint that picture for us uh
it's about 1.3 1.4 cash U total assets
about six uh
just uh don't want to go home and
twiddle my thumbs which I wouldn't do
that anyway I'm a very energetic and
outgoing person so let's stay right
there you can only travel so much now
hold on let's say right there let's
remove travel okay uhuh I think you've
allowed your mind to wander a good bit
and maybe Wonder too so we're not
twiddling our thumbs twiddling your
thumbs is not your it's not even an
option for you you just said it so
what's something that you would be
intrigued by doing or
learning what would that look like
something that kept you active we're not
talking about traveling but but what
would that look like what comes to mind
when I throw that at you because I know
there's something in
there uh I've always been interested in
working on airplanes and helicopters I'm
a mechanic by by trade um that has
always intrigued me as far as how
helicopters and all work so I haven't
even thought about it that way all right
and I'm ideating here like none of this
do I want to hang on you as well this is
what you're going to do but it's
fascinating to me that you've been a
mechanic for a long time how long you
been a mechanic oh I've been at this one
job site for 34 years 34 years and you
know you're still fascinated by fixing
something else or tinkering on something
else and it's that new challenge the way
your brain works let me throw an idea
out at you all right I want John to jump
in however he wants to jump in but here
here's what I think I think that the
fear of the unknown is probably the
greatest fear that that humans face
that's just my take okay doesn't mean
I'm right and I think that what you're
really afraid of is what does life look
like because I have been largely in a
very
controlled conditioned schedule for 34
years and on the other side of that is
all of these unknowns most of them I
think should be wonderful unknowns for
you and what's freaking you out is you
have it dug into some of these
possibilities enough to go oh not only
is this not scary it's scintilating and
I think tinkering fixing planes
helicopters all that's great but let me
throw an idea out for you what
if two or three days a week your
schedule you start fixing cars for
single moms or you get involved with a
church program that maybe has a car
donation program or you just start
finding people in your world you start
putting the word out you say you know
what I'm pretty good with mechanics and
I I'm willing to come and I'm going to
do this and maybe you just gave yourself
away doing different things but now it
wasn't for a paycheck and it was just
cuz you wanted to do it it cuz you
wanted to see a smile you wanted to see
a sigh of relief on the other side of it
how does that hit you it's funny you say
that because I'm already doing that
somewhat but that would free me up to do
it a whole lot more how much joy do you
get when you do it oh 100% that's just
one thing John what do you think you say
you want to change your neighborhood man
it'd be cool if you started a little
program for young men to come over and
learn how breakes worked and learn how
that's a great I don't know trans what a
transmission was and man what a cool
thing that would do on Sunday afternoons
at your local church just to teach young
boys how to change their own oil and
things like that that could be amazing
hey there might be a mechanical trade
school locally where they need somebody
they need instructors you we could go
all day yeah hey let me ask you this uh
Anthony um 1.2 million in cash 1.6 total
tells me you got 400,000 is that
invested or is that in your
house uh my house is not that much
house probably 100 a quarter but AAP of
automobiles and just a cash money in the
sfe for emergency okay I want you to
please please please go sit down on the
smartvestor pro and you've got way too
much
cash and with the way inflation is your
cash cash is becoming less and less
valuable every day it sits under your
bed I do hold a lot of cash personally
and so I'm not against it but you hold
you're holding a over a million dollars
worth of it right and I'm looking out
for 81y old
Anthony whose hands aren't going to let
him get under a car you know turn
wrenches or his knees aren't going to
let him get under a car anymore I want
to make sure that guy is taken care
of well I sure I hope I make it to that
818 my family tree is usually around the
75 to 78 range so you but but listen
you've bucked every Trend your family's
ever had haven't you I sure have so far
that's exactly right well let's keep it
going then let's live a long life and
man you got 20 years left to hang around
and by the way you're not going to die
at 81 I'm I'm giving it 93 that's my
guess but hey I think you can um here's
here's here's the big the the the truth
the data on
retirement that America has sold us a
bill of goods that the goal is to do
nothing the goal is to get to the end of
your day the goal is to get the end of
your job the end of your career so that
you can have the privilege of doing
nothing and this the fantasy of doing
nothing is a lie it will kill you all
the data says if you retire with nothing
your body falls apart it doesn't have a
purpose it's got nothing to pull and it
just quits cuz it's job is done so
before you quote unquote retire go ahead
and set up a schedule for yourself go
ahead and get a group of men that you're
going to have coffee with once a morning
go ahead and get one day a week at a
local community college to help out get
that schedule somewhat built you can
always back off of it but go to a thing
don't aim to do nothing no you know I
think I think the word retire should be
retired o i i well done Ken yeah I know
I worked really hard on that the last
two minutes while you were talking it's
called conception that was conception
that was that was a con conception as
James says here's what I think anthon I
really want you to look at this next
season not as retiring and John just set
that up beautifully but Reinventing
reinvent yourself because you can I like
that because you can right and and so
hey I was this for 34 years and now for
the next six weeks I'm going to be this
and then the next six weeks I'm going to
be this and the next six weeks I'm going
to be this or if I want to go the next
six months or the next six years I think
the reinvention really is the way to do
this can we look at the Anthony
diagnostic code real
quick really fast you've always been
successful you're a great teammate
you're a
millionaire what does that mean you have
built the tools you're person who
succeeds and so in the next season
you're going to get nervous you're still
going to do great man we're rooting for
you brother way to go Anthony you're
stud go help people like you already are
and watch opportunities present
themselves for you to continue to
reinvent yourself you're doing great
work man this is the Ramy
[Music]
show
he
welcome back to the ramsy show I'm Ken
Coleman Dr John delone is joining me
this hour phone number is8 8255
225 let's go to San Bernardino one of my
favorite places to say it's up there
with wala wala Washington and uh what's
the other place Shaban no
uh it's not picadillo what's the place
oh I can't now it's it's I know exactly
what you're talking about yeah we got
some trouble on that one we did that was
fun Serena joins us in San Bernardino
Serena how can we help hi thank you guys
so much for taking my call you bet
what's going on so okay so I found your
guys's radio show or your podcast like
two weeks ago and my boyfriend and I
have been listening to you guys
religiously and basically my question is
so I own a house that I have a very low
morgage on and I'm getting ready to rent
it out I'm going to make about $2,300 a
month on that rental how much do you
have left on that
mortgage 200,000 okay and you're going
to make how
much I'll make 2,300 a month on it okay
keep going
sorry okay my boyfriend owns a house his
mortgage is significantly higher he just
bought it a year ago um it's on a very
large property he rents the back
property out to his sister but now we're
talking about moving in together and he
has a friend who's willing to rent his
house out but by the end of it we would
basically be breaking even on that house
um I make about 120,000 a year he makes
about 80 so I think we could have both
houses paid off in 10 years I just want
to make sure that it's a good idea for
us to keep both of those houses rent
them out as long as we're making money
on one and breaking even on the other if
we can get it paid off in a short amount
of
time well you got a lot of stuff going
on here the Wii thing like how long you
guys been dating is this going to be a
long-term play when are we getting
married what's this what's the status
here yeah so we are eventually going to
get married we've been dating for a
little bit over a year um we he has like
3,000 wor of debt that will be paid off
in two weeks and then I owe 12,000 on my
car um that I should have paid off in
the next three
months um our plan is to eventually get
married but it's an eventual thing so
here's my thing if if that's down the
road
then then this conversation shouldn't be
framed the way you're framing it it's
your house his house and it's not a we
decision that's my take on this because
I think it's very separate right now and
here's the thing there there's the you
know we talk about being married when
you're buying houses um and people think
we're talking religious stuff which
that's a component but the big thing is
is man you're you're entering into you
and him are holding hands and walking
into
quicksand you've got a a giant home that
he wants to rent part of it he's renting
to a sister and to a brother and then to
you and then you've got a home that
you're but yall going to both try to pay
it off we only have jobs and this is the
hardest part of my job but it's being
honest with you we only have jobs
because people have plans and the plans
don't work out people break
up and so if you get divorced there is a
clear legal process for splitting things
up if you break up it all all goes to
crap it's a mess and so that's why I
would tell you you have a house that you
can choose to do with what you want to
with it and it's your house if I'm you I
would stay in my house and pay it off
yep and be completely you make 120 Grand
you have a $200,000 mortgage you can be
out of this thing in a couple of years
and be done he has chosen to
dramatically over complicate his
life by buying a huge property having
part of the mortgage relying on a sister
and then plus this and then his buddy
and what a mess it's going to be a zoo
and it's a year in right he's not he's
not relying on his sister he's owned
this house for a long time and she just
happened to buy a trailer and is renting
out the back part of the yard at this
point I thought you said just got
yearo yeah so he bought it a year ago
she just moved in two months ago into
his backyard so it's not anything that
he needs it's
just you're missing the point the point
is if you want to live with him
that's one thing but do you want to be a
landlord on your current house I mean
are you really up for being a landlord
you know because um to me you're looking
at I'm rounding down you're looking at
$25,000 a year you're making off that
house you know as opposed to just living
in it um you know so I I just I I agree
with John I think you need to take care
of your
business and he takes care of his
business on the house until there's a
Wii we don't act and talk like a Wei and
you're I want you to understand you're
going to be the living girlfriend on a
property shared between a boy and his
sister yeah and it's just I'm telling
you right now I've just done this too
long it's gonna get there's going to
come a moment when he's going to have to
choose and you're like oh he would
choose me it's just going to get messy
and I know we're ruining your day
completely totally ruining your day CU
this is even why you called you want to
know which one of these houses you want
us to sell and we're telling you neither
of them but it's it's it's we just do
this so much and we see it happen all
the time where everyone's got great
plans everybody's on the same page and
then one thing goes sideways yeah and um
if you don't have the legal protection
it gets messy yeah just because we love
you but I'd get that car paid off AAP
I'm glad you're working on that and by
the way I would not pay one penny of his
debt none not his credit card debt and
don't let him buy pay for your debt
fair right and by the way S I love your
idea listen John and I love your idea of
paying your house off in a year genius
genius now all of a sudden it's great
and listen we don't it's s of our
business who you live with and so we're
not trying to get into that but what
we're saying is
that this isn't a we conversation you
got to stop with that right if you want
to sell this house and move in with this
guy that's knock your lights out that's
your yeah go for it but you'll have sold
your house take the equity you'll have
that in an account you'll be debt free
and it's your money everything needs to
continue to be separate until there is a
Wei does that make
sense yes it does John and Ken at fun
ru.com net how do how are you feeling
about
this so honestly I feel like there a lot
going on in my head I mean I I
understand exactly what you guys are
saying like keeping everything separate
and we've had that
conversation my thing is we want to rent
a separate house and move in together
and then keep these both as rentals and
then eventually have a large rental
don't do
that
Davey Dave Ramsey went belly up doing
that you're
leveraging debt and if you remember
you're you're in uh California when just
two years ago they prohibited people
from uh evicting people who didn't pay
their
rent but the mortgages were still due
yeah and so if you get a house and
you've got a mortgage on it and he's got
a house you got a mortgage on it you'll
rent another house together and you're
trying to dude you're playing a sh
will collapse on you promise have you
done this before have you rented your
house before no I have not okay can I
okay now now I'm really going to ruin
your day okay so uh at 2,300 a month
okay that is what about 28,000 is quick
math is what you would make you said
you'd clear that much per month on the
rent right correct okay so let's call it
$288,000 is all right I have been a
homeowner for a long time and I care
about my house I can tell you about
renters they don't care about your house
they may be the most nice decent people
in the world but you're not going to see
anywhere near
$28,000 of profit this I can take to the
bank so I need you to understand that
and and John would tell you the same
thing you're not going to see anywhere
near 28 grand or 2,300 a month just bing
bing bing adding up in your account
you're going to have to take care of
that house you're the owner of the house
you're the landlord you got to deal with
everything the roof the air conditioner
the carpet when they flush too many
things down the toilet the that's why we
don't want you to rent a house that you
don't own and go rent some other house
it's just bad finances forget the
relationship piece do you get
it right I do team Serena I wanted to
sell and everybody keeps talking me into
keeping it because everybody's broke
everybody's broke Serena yeah here hey
here's the most baller play have no
mortgage at all boom nobody owns s enena
Serena can do whatever the crap she
wants she can move wherever she wants
because she has a paid off house that is
actual Financial Security having four
rental properties that the mortgage is
being paid by the T it's all a shell
game it's nonsense and by the way this
is not a moral statement but I'm going
to go this direction as your older
brother we're on team Serena here don't
live with this dude y'all be in
relationship don't live with him make
him commit to
you okay that's just my take and not a
moral imperative but that's just
relationship and don't move into a place
where the sister is too yeah there you
go this is the Ramy
[Music]
show
welcome back America you're listening to
the ramsy show we're so excited to have
you I'm Ken Coleman Dr John delone
sitting next to me here
88255 225 is the phone number that's
8825 5225 boisey Idaho is where we go
now Sarah's there Sarah how can we help
hi yeah so I'm I'm 18 years old I
graduated high school about a year ago
um and I am just really hesitant to
start college or even trying to even
think about going to college I've just I
have no idea even if I should or what I
even should do I'm just really confused
oh okay well first of all great news is
you're 18 okay yeah and so being 18 is
confusing and it's been confusing for
18y olds for every decade uh for a very
very long time because you are still
developing you're still maturing and
there's this big daunting thing called
the future staring at you and and when
you don't have a lot of mechanisms to
try to navigate the future it gets even
more intimidating then you just shut
down and all your creativity kind of
goes away does that sound about right
yeah you pretty good you got a spot on
there yeah all right so I I've been uh
helping people figure this out for years
and years and years and I think what we
have to do is simplify okay so let's
first let's take on the first part of
the question uh we don't even consider
College until we figure out Direction
and I think direction is more important
than destination destination can change
but if I'm heading in the right
direction in my life okay financially
relationally spiritually professionally
if I'm headed in the right direction
destination can change and I'm and I'm
not losing track so I think I want to
forget about destination and we start to
go what about Direction so college right
now is not even on the table because
unless the degree is the only way to go
the direction you want to go um uh or
it's the best way then we know there's
another way does that make sense to you
yeah all right so let's put that over
here on the side okay so 18 you've been
out of college for a year I mean out of
high school for a year okay okay yeah I
want to know I don't care if it goes
back to 9-year-old Sarah 12-year-old
Sarah 14 what I don't care I want to
know the things that you have allowed
yourself when you felt safe maybe in
your room driving a car whatever sitting
in a an assembly at high school or a
boring class and you wondered about what
would it be like to do this when I grow
up what are the things that maybe were
pretty consistent or maybe the things
that you got most excited about when you
allowed yourself to do that well all
throughout High School I kind of had a
plan for myself to try to get into
medical school but recently I've just I
don't know I got cold feet a while ago
i' I work in a in a medical office now
and I've kind of realized like I kind of
hesitated thinking if I don't think I
could do that for the rest of my life
with patience um I've also like I had a
moment of really loving astronomy I've
always you know I've always loved you
know learning about all that um I also
one of the biggest things was wanting to
maybe try to teach English out in
foreign Nations like maybe somewhere in
Europe or maybe somewhere on the East
Asian countries I've I've always had a
interest in that okay so Sarah I see a
pattern here and I want you to tell me
if I'm if I'm not seeing this correctly
uh in those three different options I
see two very clear people focused ideas
and then I see some learning I think I
think you're a learner I think you like
knowledge and and what knowledge does
for people is that fair yeah yeah and I
also think you really like people work
like taking care of people or doing
something with people I think that's the
theme I see in the medical side of
things or teaching a language I think
you're a people focused person is that
true yeah I can see that yeah okay so
real quick I don't want to get you stuck
in the weeds but I think you could take
the entire world of work every job in
the world and I think you can organize
them into four buckets people
work idea work process work and object
work what I mean by object is you're
working with your hands and your head
but you're fixing something building
something does that make
sense okay so John and I are in people
work and idea work right we our work
kind of is in both buckets ideas in the
form of content John's books things that
he creates to help people so John and I
are both people and ideas that's where
you would put us so I think you're in
the people side of things but I I think
there may be a little bit of process
there in that education piece now I just
want to know how does that hit you or is
there another bucket that you go I
identify with I'm good at people stuff
and I'm good at process
stuff there's there's always a
connection with those four does that
make sense yeah all right what are you
feeling
um I feel like that is just kind of what
I've always thought about doing I mean
um yeah I mean yeah so here's the deal
so here's what I want you to do let's
now let's go okay we know that medical
work at least the type of medical work
you're seeing in this office is not for
you you got up close and I love that but
I want you to step back and go how are
what are all the different ways that I
could take care of people see because if
you're in the healthc care world you're
caring for people but there's a lot of
ways to care for people teaching them a
language is a form of caring for people
so I got a three-part exercise that I'm
not going to make you answer on the air
and I want to bring John into because I
know he's got some great thoughts here
he's worked with college students for a
long long time I want you to answer
three questions in the near future I
want you to look at it almost every day
and I like a pencil because allows me me
creative and I can erase and answer
every day differently three questions
can you write them down
yeah yeah all right here we go first one
is who are the people that I most want
to
help get specific say students in Peru
one day the next day say uh people that
are aging and uh and I want to help them
in convalescent homes or whatever I
don't care every day if the answer
changes let it go and write it down no
wrong answer who are the people I most
want to help now the second question is
after I answer the first one those
people describe them then I want you to
answer what problem or desire do those
people
have and you write it down no wrong
answer third question what are the
solutions to those people's problem or
desire that I most get excited
about you got it okay yeah now here's
what's going on this is a construct John
for ideation and I think that this is
what we don't teach kids this is as dumb
of a plan as I've ever heard in my life
but it works and the reason what it does
is allows me to ideate from my heart
what moves my heart and then I match it
up with that last question is where is
my talent yeah what am I good at and
what am I good at that can actually be a
part of the solution or what can I go
get training on to become good at to get
better that's right I have some raw
talent that with training education and
experience becomes a skill that's right
so Sarah I want you to take everything
he said and I want you to lay on top of
this Foundation here okay okay when I
was 18 years old I went to college to be
a youth Minister that lasted about three
weeks evidently you got to read the
Bible all the time so I'm out
right I then was went into uh become a
journalism major I did that for about a
year and then I realized how much
journalists made and so then I went over
to be business then in business evident
you got to take math classes because you
have to balance balance sheets and I was
lost at seat
and then I went and saw a movie in the
theater called Goodwill Hunting and I
went that next Monday and changed my
major cuz I wanted to be Robin Williams
I wanted to be a counselor at a small
College behind closed doors and then
they said hey we're out of Majors for
you've taken too many classes all over
the campus we can get you enough
psychology classes so you can go to
graduate school and um but you have to
have a Humanities degree so my degree is
in Humanities end up being a great
degree history writing
psychology then I went to grad school
for psychology right no for education
and I got a master's in education a PhD
in education and then I went and got
another PhD in counseling and you know
what I do now I'm a YouTuber I have a
podcast podcasting and YouTube did not
exist when I was
18 all I that to say is this there is no
wrong step for you moving forward follow
the plan kin maap out for you and then
hold it all really Loosely that's right
every step you take is going to be a
step either like I'm not going to step
there again or I like this all that is
data moving you forward it's a great
story it's it's back to what I said
direction is more important than
destination what we can see if there was
a theme though for all those things it
was people I like to help people and and
that's the key great call thank you
Sarah this is the Ry
[Music]
show
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman Dr John delone is sitting
alongside
8825 5225 is the number 8825 5225 time
for our scripture and quote of the day
we start with Hebrews 10:23 and 24 let
us un let us hold unswervingly to the
hope we profess for he who promised is
faithful and let us consider how we may
spur one another on toward love and Good
Deeds our quote of the day from Nick
Sabin a little moment of silence for all
Alabama
all right that's enough he's retired not
dead but Bobby the engineer is in the
control room and that was for you sir uh
it's gonna be okay I promise you'll
still win some football games it's not
going to be
okay L listen to this guy the Texas Tech
guy taking a shot I get it all right
Nick sa's quote mediocre people do not
like high Achievers and high Achievers
do not like mediocre
people wow that's a that's a true that's
as true a quote as quotes could be true
I think that's true I think there's an
aster I think some mediocre people like
working for high Achievers because they
create a lot of paychecks I yeah well
they don't like the uh he's right
completely but you're right they like
they like the Halo they like what they
get from the high achiever but when it
comes down to it high Achievers make
mediocre people feel uncomfortable yeah
high standards I love it boy that's not
2024 woke approved Pro that statement
that's a little too harsh Nick but hey
he can say whatever he wants so you know
why he's not on social media and if he
was he doesn't care what you think
anyway and he wins he does win a lot
Ashley is GNA win I just feel it John
she's in Jacksonville Florida she is on
the show nowley what's up oh I Like That
Ashley how can we help hi Ken hi Dr John
thanks so much for taking my call really
an honor it's an honor to get to see
with you both so thank you what's going
on um so I'm in the advanced stages of
interviewing for basically my dream job
wow that's usually not what people say
on the back end of the phrase I'm in the
advanced stages of I didn't expect that
either now don't just fly by that are
you are you comfortable telling this
what this dream job is um I'm not
allowed to share the company but it's a
graphic yeah it's a graphic design
position um I would be working on a lot
of really cool projects and things that
I've really been interested in for a
long time so Ashley that's freaking
congratulations awesome can just say way
to go okay so you're almost there we
haven't landed it yet but you're on your
way what's up yeah so I'm obviously
really excited about that but the only
thing I'm nervous about is if I were to
get the offer I would clearly have to
tell my current employer that I'm
leaving and I don't really know how to
do that um yeah I work for a really
really small family run company so it
feels really personal when people leave
and I don't want to come off as like
sneaky or dishonest in any way yeah so I
just I want some good advice on how to
bring up leaving or giving a two weeks
notice in that situation' come it's
really to the end do that walk in the
office with that plane and if you can
get a '90s era boom box on your shoulder
it will lighten the room for sure um
Ashley say anything yeah um here here I
don't I don't know what John's gonna say
I'm gonna what I think is the most
simple advice on this um I think you
have to put yourself
in in almost a roleplay scenario and I
want you to be your
boss and I want you to think about how
you would want Ashley to tell you some
really exciting news for
Ashley pretty exciting and uh and I want
you to think about how would you want
you to tell the boss I mean that's the
idea it's like if you're the boss how
would you want you to say it and what
comes to mind just free flow How would
how would you want to be told this
information you know probably like I've
really enjoyed my time here I've had a
great experience and you guys have
really made me feel comfortable and
loved here um but I feel like it's time
for me to grow and I found another
opportunity that will possibly help me
in that direction well let me say this I
put myself in your boss's shoes while
you were talking and if you said that to
me I would be sad
but I would not be mad now I'm healthy
so you may not get that reaction John
but I think that was pretty darn good so
here's my two critiques of that oh I've
got two critiques you ready for this
take it easy break your heart here I
will take them I want feedback
um anytime I'm using the word
but giving somebody hard
news it always gives them an opportunity
to hang on to something heavy during a a
very um scary moment a sad moment a
heartbreaking moment an emotional moment
so I really loved what you did for me
here but I need to grow which in some
ways is an indictment of them it's not
but they can take it as that they can
hang on to it I've loved everything
you've taught me but I think I can get
more over
here think about it this way and
flipping it around and saying I have a
really tough conversation I need to have
with you and you sit down you look at
him and
say for the rest of my life I'm going to
be grateful for the opportunity you gave
me I've recently selected another
position at another company it's an
amazing opportunity for me and so here's
my twoe
notice as I leave here I want you to
know I love you guys and forever if I
can do something to support you um I'm
here for you okay then there's a period
and listen you need to know this on the
front end there's no words you can use
to make this a little bit less hard it's
just going to be uncomfortable yeah cuz
you love them they love you and you're
moving on it's just hard yeah they may
or may not I really like that breakdown
that's next level analysis she was off
the cuff she was actually I want I want
to build you up and say that it's about
the spirit not about the words and uh
let me just say and I mentioned it a
moment ago uh there's no guarantee that
you handling it the way that you're
going to handle it love that and very
important is going to get the desired
result that you want which is them to go
oh my gosh Ashley we're so excited for
you we're going to be sad but oh my gosh
right like that's what we want and so
I'm leading to something here I cannot
tell you how many times Ashley on the
Ken Coleman show I've had somebody call
in and say this very thing and they're
going I'm dealing with guilt and so I
want to go ahead and get preemptive on
this um you do everything the right way
John gave you great advice I think that
was fabulous you do it that way that's
all you can control is how you do it but
let me tell you something you cannot
allow yourself to feel guilt about
leaving people who have given you a
great opportunity because you are
leaving to another great opportunity and
one does not cancel out the other in
other words you taking another great
opportunity doesn't crap on people who
gave you the first opportunity that's
really important guilt is something that
I feel if I've done something wrong
something illegal something unethical
whatever and so it's natural because
good people feel that way and I think
John I'm bringing you back in here uh
because I think we are so worried about
what people are going to say about us
and think about us I am chief Center
here so I'm speaking from a a guy who is
a people pleaser off the charts bottom
line is this is a great opportunity
handle yourself well and move on I want
you to speak to that I think most of us
have such um contrary to what the media
would tell us I think most people have
really rich Hearts I think so and they
don't want to be the cause of some body
else's tears that's good and so I will
end up squashing myself I'll squash
opportunities I'll squash hard
conversations because I don't want to
cause you pain and what we have to
realize is that's kind of egotistical
that's not our job yeah my job way
they're going to be okay without you
actually and by the way over the last
few years you've brought them a lot too
I know you're good at what you do
otherwise you wouldn't be being hired at
this rad new company yeah and so it's
been business and it's been relational
and you know from past experience how
they're probably going to respond lose
their mind talk crap about you hug you
cry say how dare you get out of here you
kind of know what's coming and so the
more you can keep that with an open hand
and know I treated them with dignity I
gave them I gave them notice I was
honest I didn't say yeah but I mean if
you had given or I always always had
this Ken always have a number what's the
number when they go what if we doubled
your salary what if we triple it like
because you find yourself in a situ like
I think great advice just know no I'm my
time is done here thank you very much
with a period yeah and I think Ashley
you're taking this new gig for the lad
not the money the money's going to come
but you're excited about the work yeah
yes of course way to go ashle proud of
you Ashley it's amazing you're an
absolute rock star really proud of you
Ashley thank you for the call Dr John
always good to be uh in the scrubs with
you here the metaphorical scrubs not
that kind of doctor I know just making
bad jokes but we both are wearing scrubs
James Childs our fearless leader and all
the guys in in the booth to keep us on
the air and you America thank you this
is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show